Our future president,
slash, amazing source
of vitamin C, Donald Trump...
-(laughter) ...recently met
with Barack Obama
to go over the transition
of power
and also to ask
"What do presidents do?"
(laughter)
This is...
(cheers and applause)
This is the exact moment
of it just sinking in,
what he's got to do right here.
And Obama's like,
"Yeah, mother(bleep), that's
what this (bleep) is about."
-(laughter)
-According to CNBC,
aides on Trump's team
were surprised to learn
the entire West Wing staff
will leave with Obama,
which is a bummer, 'cause Trump
was really looking forward
to saying, "You're fired!"
to a bunch of housekeepers.
-(laughter) -Trump was also
reportedly planning
to split his time between
Washington D.C., Trump Tower
and Mar-a-Lago because he
doesn't want this job, you guys!
-He doesn't want to do it.
-(applause and cheering)
He didn't think it through.
-He just didn't
think it through. -Yeah.
Right? This is like
a Twilight Zone ending for Trump
where he gets
his Faustian bargain.
"You mean I actually have
to do this?! No!"
-Yeah, but... think about it.
-(cheers and applause)
He's a billionaire,
he's 70 years old.
The next four to eight years
are a considerable chunk
of the rest of his life,
and he's got
to (bleep) do it now.
It's hilarious. I mean, it's...
(applause and cheering)
I don't know how funny it is
to some people, but
it seems like
Donald doesn't know
what the presidency
actually entails.
He's like America's drunk friend
watching American Ninja Warrior,
saying,
-"Yeah, I could do that
(bleep)." Except... -(laughter)
"It's not so hard.
I could do that (bleep)."
Except now,
60 million people were like,
"Okay, then do that (bleep),
why don't you?"
-(laughter,
applause and cheering) -Now,
comedians,
since the president-elect needs
some helping hints
to get started,
what are some other presidential
duties he should know about?
Arden Myrin.
Presiding over the government
of the United States of America.
-(laughter)
-All right.
-(applause and cheering)
Well, a branch of it.
Yeah. Points.
-Judge Doug Benson.
-(laughter)
-I...
I don't...
I don't know exactly
how the custom works, Chris,
but I think
around the holidays,
he has to choose a turkey
and grab its lady giblets.
-(laughter)
-HARDWICK: All right.
-Points. Yeah.
-(applause and cheering)
-Samm Levine.
-He's got to
renew trade agreements
with other countries.
He has to negotiate the
cease fire in the Middle East.
He has to reduce
the federal budget.
I'm just (bleep) with you,
Donnie.
Mike Pence will handle all that.
Don't worry about it.